so guys listen welcome to the new
channel this is basically an opportunity
for us to do more laid-back stuff
quizzes competitions cooking challenges
shooting challenges inviting guests
cooking challenges
yeah we might look like a cookoff bro
i'm roasting your ass you know you're
gonna be roasting the food you're not
roasting
you know i got like three four dishes
that are gonna kill anything you gotta
make three four bro
hold up you've got three four hold on
hold on hold on hold on you guys
you got a good steak that's not that
impressive nobody cares you think i got
steak i just got stayed
you think i just got your wife loves you
so she has to say the food's good it's
okay yeah yeah
yeah
but uh today we're going to be doing a
couple of different things what do we do
at first two two two lives i don't know
you tell me
you set that [ __ ] up yeah quiz master we
got we've seen behind the camera yeah
with female music you're not gonna see
him yes not today you're gonna see him
in the future so uh what do you wanna go
with first let's do two truths in a lie
let's start with it do truth one lie all
right all right all right so the way
this one works is we've uh submitted
two lies and one truth uh about five
different times two was seen and then
the other person across from us is gonna
have to guess which one is the truth out
of the three options cool cool so why
don't we uh you want to go with me or
preachers first i'll go with you just
because i have it up front go back and
forth boom all right so so read out the
uh the three to preach and preach you're
gonna have to guess
which one i'm telling the truth on
coke
easy peasy lemon squeezy all right two
truths one lie abba edition here we go
number one
i know how to skateboard
okay
two
i could tolerate a flat booty in a
partner
okay
third one i once peed on a lifeguard
uh
i know you're supposed to
i know
i know you're supposed to um
ask questions and stuff like that you
know what i mean i know you're supposed
to be like okay
so
in your partners you know i'm supposed
to be like so where did you but the
skateboard thing is from ottawa all
right and he got here late
so
and i've seen him walk he's weird when
he's walking what the [ __ ] you eat
what's that dude there's handy yeah
there's dudes with no legs on
skateboards the [ __ ] you mean how [ __ ]
up you are anyways so moving on
[Laughter]
okay you're on the first one this man is
violating go ahead i chose violence yeah
i could tell go ahead okay so judging by
the way you walk you can you can dance
but your dancing is like a succession
of stumbles
[Laughter]
wow why am i why am i like this okay why
am i like
and i've seen the girls you date and i
think you can tolerate a flat booty
[Applause]
yo why are you causing problems i don't
do that for your marriage why are you
[ __ ] up my meeting with you i'm just
chilling
all right so which one you think is a
lie huh
i think i think the truth is um
you're the kind of [ __ ] that's going to
pee on the lighting
you you look at you dude look at you
look at this look at you look at you
don't you look like a [ __ ] that won't
be on the left guard
i wish they could zoom on your ass right
now
no it's the booty
it's the booty
booty is the
truth tolerate is the word
i could tolerate he could tolerate it
but if you too much about [ __ ]
he gonna be like
you got a flat booty anyway
to all the flat booty women who are
watching from home right now you're
about to be heartbroken i cannot
tolerate a flat booty i peed on a
lifeguard
[Applause]
you're allowed to pee on people yeah
yeah who raised you
yo don't don't talk about my mom
watch how you do that today you're
moving
the first episode
did he get stung by a jellyfish you were
just like [ __ ] this dude duh you know
what it was is uh my sister had to
babysit me all the time and she used to
hate babysitting me my mom would just
dump her with me and then she's like you
have to hang out with your older sister
because i gotta go do some stuff
and i used to like going to the pool i
love going to the pool yeah but my
sister used to hate having to come to
the pool and i was like you got to take
me [ __ ] because i'm bored
so
so all of a sudden all of a sudden she
started enjoying going
you know what i'm saying and how's it
and we're sitting in front of the pool
we're not saying we're standing in front
of like the pool gate and she's just
sitting there talking to this lifeguard
and i'm like trying to go inside she's
just having a good time
[ __ ] no
and i was just staring and i swear to
god
pulled out my shorts i started peeling
because what my sister told me she said
like all we heard was a noise and then
he's like he started screaming i was
there like this
so
yes and i told violet today that's how
you know i'm a bad sibling bro i saw my
sister happy
and i peed on the man she was talking to
trash oh is this so this is some
gangster [ __ ] yeah wow
oh is this something you like but now
is that what peeing looks like with you
stupid
so i'm stupid you'll be on the line
you're all for
all one all right hit me with the next
set
oh for one we're gonna go back and forth
here yeah let's go go back and forth
okay
your turn
next one preach
preach once broke someone's teeth with a
rear naked choke
punch
preach once broke someone's teeth a
preacher is just violent
with a cane with a kick it was a kick
not we don't know what kind but with a
kick or was it with a punch or was it a
rear naked joke
see punching someone in the face with a
punch makes sense
it's too easy
this [ __ ] is complicated
i just feel like
this man is complicated
complicated now broke someone's
my
kick i feel like that's something you
would have done in school
when you were younger it's possible you
feel me he seemed like the type to the
school like when every [ __ ] was
punching he would just start kicking you
know i mean
i feel like that and i feel like a rare
naked choke is something you would do
because you've been learning
and you're a bouncer
but breaking someone's teeth with a rear
naked choke yo [ __ ] show them your arms
but yeah whatever damn that's a tough
one
i spent them all my life
i think you've broken a lot of teeth i
feel like all three of these could be
true simultaneously
maybe you [ __ ] gave up you just said
three truths
[Laughter]
that is false
which one was it it was a rear naked
choker
yeah
more complicated than we thought avril
lavigne
okay what happened was
i had to pull this guy out of the bar
right
because he was he was going around
people you know the whole joke of
tapping one shoulder and then you're
near the other side he was doing that
and when [ __ ] would turn he
would take your drink and chug it
nobody feels bad for him right now no no
i suppose yeah yeah he was doing that he
did that to six seven people
and he was already intoxicated when he
got inside the bar so he was just
chugging people's beard and when i took
him out he's like i want to go you get
the [ __ ] out he took a last one
i was like get out huh
yo get the [ __ ] out
he turned around and pushed him through
the door
he grabbed me we fell down we scuffle a
bit
i try to like scuffle whatever he takes
my radio off whatever blah blah i
neutralize them where they could choke
just to put them to sleep and i'm gonna
ground
i lock my legs and everything and stuff
and i look on the ground and two of my
dreads on the ground
he pulling [ __ ] out he pulled them
[ __ ] out
in the scuffle so while doing this
because when you you're like this right
you just have to tighten it so
his mouth is right here so i switch from
this
to this so now it's just this and i went
on my forearm and then i heard
[Music]
yo you guys heard it first man that's
the price of two dreads
some [ __ ] teeth that's brutal
[ __ ] but it's just
but he deserved it
the moment he was doing this and
grabbing people's drinks i'm like wait a
minute yeah
i'm i'm gently taking you out the door
and i'm like you have to go now stop
[ __ ] around go out
and then you you try to fight your fear
you're taking people's dreams
and then you pull my head
off
so that's what happened that's some game
of thrones [ __ ]
that's him like that
[Music]
that's why i just i just switched push
his stance on him yeah
though all right abba
abba likes uk women's makeup
abba likes uk women's makeup uk women's
makeup
okay let that settle
abba lost his car the same day he bought
it
[Applause]
okay cool everyone
or abba got a bj on a jet ski
okay what's the thing about uk women
what do you think about the
well uk women
they they use makeup very differently
than the rest of the world yeah and i'm
i'm a big fan of uk women
you know how i feel about the black
women over there yeah
that's it
okay
what happened with your claw
well i lost at the same time about how
did you lose it well basically what
ended up happening is that
police officers were involved and i
shouldn't have had the car
what
you shouldn't have the car that's the
best i could do for you
and the [ __ ] he's going to be like i
had a blog i lived i i lived i lived in
boredom there was a place called wasaga
beach yeah and uh i rented jet skis for
the first time you know my boy mustafa
shout out to you
he got me on a jet ski i was like nah
nah we don't do that water [ __ ] what
about the shark she's like yo
what's up you're stupid yeah listen i
think baywatch okay
so i got all the jet skis and we happen
to be there with some girls and you know
what i'm saying the first time was a
special time
uh which one is the truth i think the
makeup and you can women
okay
i don't have the answer but i got a
question now were you driving the jet
ski while actively getting no i'm not
stupid
because if you ever been on a jet ski
if you you got a death wish or she does
she does not value her life and she's
sucking you off while you're doing a jet
ski getting car getting head in the car
is not the same at all no a jet skis
bump yourself
it depends where you are
different montreal is the same thing as
a jet ski
i bought this buick 1997 teal okay 750
it already had like 200 like 150k
mileage geez i have to go with my first
instinct because i already went that's
united that is me you've been right both
times with your first instinct
so
i go off base
uh to go buy the car and i purchased a
vehicle from this like old white dude
and the thing had no plates on it right
but i only needed to take it back to the
parking lot so i could just set it there
and so it was like five minute drive so
i grabbed the car get in sign the
paperwork take it away and as i'm
driving by uh on base i'm passing by the
gym and there's a military police an mp
stopping somebody and he's going through
like a ticket and he sees me drive by
and i see his eyes light up
but so i only have two minutes to go to
the parking lot the way this man eyes
lit up i started panicking so i kept
driving this man abandoned his thing
jumped into the car because he saw i had
no plates on
so he went swirled sorry he didn't have
yeah oh he's like never possible
oh the place wow you really trust the
police i never forget this he he pulls
me over a minute away from like the the
the barracks and all the guys are there
so the guys are coming out the breaks
they see me getting pulled over first i
was like [ __ ] you got a car i'm like
not anymore
they took it away they took away the car
because i didn't have any insurance on
it and i didn't have any
place plates
so i lost the car and he's like this how
much it's going to cost to tow it back
and how much it cost to tow it back was
how much i pretty much paid for it
yeah i paid 7.50 so i'm like i'm not
going to pay more money no for a hoop no
so i had to go to court
to go pay for not having insurance and
you know how having that insurance is
immediately thousand dollars yes five
thousand dollars yeah over there yeah in
ontario yeah damn how much is it here
for new insurance uh no insurance is
about a thousand five thousand five okay
so it's five g's right sometimes they
lower it to three spots i'm i'm in court
i'm watching everybody go in everybody
getting shafted and i'm like i got five
cheese brother
this is the most expensive
yay
so she says okay so yes your turn for no
insurance because she just gave other
people 5g so it's like it's your turn
and i'm like all right i didn't have an
insurance should i call you guilty i'm
like yes uh and she's like okay and she
looks like he's like you were on
fc board military bases again it's like
750 bucks
yeah
turns out the laws are different on the
military yeah so i only have to pay 750.
yeah i i just i paid 750 to lose another
750 and that was it that's how i bought
my car the same day literally within 10
minutes of buying it i lost it
the special one i'm just gonna go yeah
i'm the complicated one he's a special
one yeah [ __ ] all right
you're the violent abusive one taking
out [ __ ] teeth
yeah that's right well you made you look
good though
everybody here thought he deserved it
you thought the guy deserved it he took
out your dreads
you're stealing people's drinks yeah
[ __ ] that i'm not gonna go out out of my
way to be violent
i'm not gonna go out of my way
but if you come in you you're gonna go
to miami
that was not out of my way i was about
to go there see
i was it just it just sort of happened
that i was in my hand so it was not out
of my way all right it was not out of my
way the ones who know no the ones who
don't know all right let's hit the next
one oh [ __ ] with me i'm like clan
[Music]
anyways all right
[Laughter]
all right we're going we're going to uk
with this one a little bit okay
so preach doesn't know jimmy carr
jimmy carr calls preach sensei
or preach once gave jimmy carr a lift
in his jimmy carter
you can tell he's been holding on to
that one for him
you know what the second one is so
strange i just think it's the second one
i think i think he called him sensei
and him calling you sensei doesn't sound
possible no but you're a weird [ __ ]
yeah you have weird situations
i believe that he would have called you
sensei you probably met up once and
y'all was talking and you just had that
kind of authority figure no what
happened was i was chilling at just for
laughs okay and i was with mike uh
poseidon and and pentalis
and i was there chilling too but i had
my bathroom one
and
he's like
are you the are you the man that i've
seen last year like yeah i was with my
oh all right and then we leave
how are you doing we're good cool we go
chit chat with the word thing and then
mike and us we're supposed to go to
another party and he asked we passed by
the table where jimmy carr is reviewing
his jokes for the roast
and mike asked him if he wanted to go to
uh the party and he said i'll join you
later and i was like okay cool see you
later uh take care of yourself jimmy
he's like all right see you later sensei
but he's just looking there he
i don't believe jimmy car would have
given him a ride
i feel like when you get that i gave it
right to jimmy carter oh that's the
thing yeah i feel like when you get that
rich it's just uber everywhere you know
you know you don't take rights from you
but i did the thing with i gave it right
okay and that would be part possible as
well
yeah but anyways i got it so that's one
one for me zero for preach
let's go to the next one baby all right
so abba abba's first girlfriend cheated
on him
abba made a fire mixtape of beets when
he was 17.
fire subjective just let me say that
fire is better i think i think it's fire
it's very suggesting
or the count of monte cristo is abba's
favorite book
oh yeah that's a c
c that's a good book c that's a good one
c
preacher's favorite book too
no it's a good book i really think that
i really think that your first
girlfriend did cheat on you because
that's that's the type of [ __ ] you are
uh
that's just you know [ __ ] i mean mm-hmm
but the kind of munchie cristo is a
[ __ ] good book it's a good book you
ready so
no i don't read you know i don't read do
you think i read i saw the movie
uh but i think you read it in school
they made you read it so it's not so
much they they don't make you read that
book in school that's that's like the
three musketeers they don't make you
read this [ __ ] yeah they do you made you
read three musketeers yeah
i don't know
yeah i think it's that one
that is that one yeah
yeah that's a fire book i do not read
but when i used to write no no that's a
fire that book was unbelievable if
you've never read alexander zuma's work
ten out of ten he's the one who made the
man in the iron mask as well as the
three musketeers the movie's stretched
but the books are really good yes i
agree yes
i highly recommend but you can't the
book is so rich you can't put
unbelievable with a better prayer of
revenge yes you know what i mean like i
feel like that's why i got my
inspiration to be petty from yes yeah
absolutely i mean imagine just waiting
20 years to [ __ ] over everybody who
[ __ ] your that's beautiful i got
[ __ ] lined up on a little list yeah
yeah about to smack them with some money
yeah so make sure you subscribe in the
mouth
all right we're 1-1
1-1 i'm hyped i want to read this book i
want to learn to read yeah
so what are you watching on your phones
bro
he probably got a little background
alexa
i got hieroglyphs and [ __ ] here
you guys can't tell he's arab that's why
that's funny yeah
you couldn't tell by my cell tree voice
all right reach yeah
the fastest preach has gone on a
motorcycle is 290.
the fastest preacher kilometers per hour
kilometers i didn't have the units
that's good all right
if you were going miles per hour think
i'm like you a plane
that's fast
you have to start using mock speed or
some [ __ ]
290 miles per hour
on a motorcycle on a motorcycle okay
so this is three top speeds right so
what's the fastest preachers got on a
motorcycle is it 290
kilometers per hour 310
kilometers per hour or 260 kilometers
per hour
this [ __ ] likes going fast
that's guaranteed
i do
i bet a passenger in your car
i like to be efficient
sure and going official to get it
somewhere yeah sure not fishing for
safety oh wait a minute i'm safe
i'm safe
for for someone who goes very very fast
i'm safe you a [ __ ] but i'm safe hey
what happened to your other car didn't
it catch on fire
no that was my first yeah yeah yeah this
nigga's car caught on fire on a highway
hey you know what it was it was a remote
no it was a remote control
for the the starter sure it got wired
all i know is this guy got a car
self-emulated but anyways
okay i mean you know speeds is tough 260
290 310 like yeah you know
i don't know uh
i would say
mama
[Laughter]
uh
i'm insane
[Music]
you're gonna say he's gonna say speed
that you didn't even mention
i'm going to say 150 i'm like
on a motorcycle
let me just think about this
well [ __ ] going 120 that's fast
broke you know on the highway it's
pretty
you're going 180 that's fast it's basic
then you go to 200 that's that's very
fast
you go to 250 that's very fast
i guess the point's almost dangerous
i don't think he did 310 that's
dangerous that's too much i think he's
got a wife and kids that he wants to go
back to kid's not actually here but i
think he wants one
she's between 260 and 290.
now 290 may be too unreasonable and i
just can't tell because i lost my first
car the first day i bought it
so i don't know
260 is also crazy fast
i think for a thrill he went to 290.
you're right
give me that
give me that give me that you see
yeah i like that
[ __ ]
yeah watson
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay stop playing with me
stop playing with
all right yeah well deduced
i've been a passenger too in creatures
calm down
calm down now
am i am i unsafe
let's just say it's exciting hey
i'm so excited
hey there you go
i just you know that's exactly how i
describe my sex life
people like is it safe i'm like it's
you exciting
all right hit us all right
we tied now to a piece no no one oh it's
two one yeah i keep a score i'm not
playing all right no he's not playing
definitely all right let's go all right
we're back to abba
so abba's favorite music genre
is it house music
is it salsa music
or is it haitian company ah that depends
bro
that depends bruh
no
that's it's like the it's like the
okay from my zone it's not it's not
compact
it's not compact
it's not compromised
house is nice
it's between house and salsa
but there's something about someone that
hits you
the proper sauce of sound god
house is nice
i'm a house head
you could be a househead and still like
some other stuff you understand what i'm
saying i really think it's salsa i
really think it's salsa ah
no i'm gonna switch that up
final answer final answer
you are correct yeah
that's good you've done it but that's
our favorite
it's 181b
like that
all right
it's it was between the house and salsa
you know not like that you like it but
you don't put it like that
not like hops
okay all right and the sausage i gotta
give it to he's good yeah i i like
[ __ ] give me that come down all
right let's go two two's good
come on
come on listen yours are obscure and
very hard to guess yeah uh 290 280 260.
it's like [ __ ]
how am i supposed to know any doesn't
matter let's go
watch
do i like oranges do i like apples or do
i like grapes [ __ ] talk about
makeup and flat booty shut up yeah at
least that's more interesting that's
more entertaining
all right look at the who let's go hide
all right we're back to preach
so did preach
escape the police on a bike
on foot or in the car there you go there
you go you got it get the [ __ ] out of
here
what was my mode of transportation what
was it
what was it so it was if we got it
on feet on car on foot or bike that's
right
i'm not even a lot of you if you told me
this thing you escaped on all three i
believe you
simultaneously
[Music]
i feel like you start on a bike you
robbed a car you dropped the car and
then you just ran
grand theft auto um
escape the police
i'm going to stay on foot
on footage falls
car
i could see that
i was not going to be able to use this
one
all three of them sounded very plausible
look at this nigga's face he looks like
someone who belongs on a mug shot after
running away
i'm gonna take that one
all right who was 290.
i know i didn't have to i feel like you
would have also done it on a bike maybe
i'm crazy no no no no no only on only on
a car
i wouldn't win all right next one get
away
i wouldn't i don't buy you
but you got away on this especially not
like
yeah
but i yeah i kind of
never mind yeah we don't want to get
into no we don't need to get don't tell
ourselves
don't tell yourself hit us i have an
appetite for speaking
you don't have a problem i have an
appetite for speed
let's go
i will say when we drove you had me
remembering prayers i forgot in arabic
that's all the muslims are watching
[Laughter]
allah
[Music]
let's go all right last one here
abba is a prince
abba is open to having a muslim wife
or abba walked out on a date
mid-conversation
abba is a prince
if either abba is a prince or abba
walked out
conversation and be like
all right [ __ ]
left i could see him do that but i'm
gonna go with abba is a prince you don't
think i'd have a muslim wife no wanna no
just know
really yeah interesting no
not so interesting just no you wouldn't
hey listen go transition yeah
muslim wife [ __ ] out of here
um
he either a prince like it's more
plausible that you're a prince then you
have a muslim wife you know what i mean
it's more plausible that you're a prince
it's more plausible that you want
mid-conversation deadpool style when
deadpool is bored of a conversation he
shoots himself in the head out of
respect hold up you see me walk away
you see me walk away mid conversation
from regular people all the time
because some people do not need to be
talked to yeah
but abba is a prince
final answer
your final answer
is correct
i know
abba is a prince yeah i know that that's
[ __ ] wild but i told you at some
point i told you i was like
wait a [ __ ] minute
you [ __ ] is royalty you remember that i
told you that
you said oh yeah we supposed to go to
blah blah blah
that i knew
but this [ __ ] the way he is
he's still he's still uh
he walked out of his throne the same way
you would walk out of a conversation
with him
and be like i ain't about that life bye
megan let's go
like this [ __ ] married to meghan
markle so now we had two three preach
yep we got last one for preach here
preach
once closed an andrew schultz show
preach once opened
an andrew schultz
preach once hosted
an andrew scholzo open close or host it
getting close
oh
it's between opening and hosting
he loves hosting
but i don't think andrew would have let
him host
so i'm leaning towards the opened
how do you feel about tall white juice
tall white juice
i ain't walking in that one [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
he's irish he looks true he's irish
that is irish shultz is a jew name i
thought he was i thought he was thinking
i looked it up and he's not she's irish
i think he doesn't look irish you got
pale skin it don't matter not all right
people are [ __ ] rare
leprechauns
no we ain't
somebody google his man's jew not that
it really matters i just want to make
that clear
reveal the jew i'm pretty sure he's a
jew
jewish
jewish did you google jewish angels of
scottish
he's jew hold on
scottish and german irish descendant
he's german
jew i just googled it this
motherfucker's not believing me
it could be a scholar
cameron he's andrew cameron
i was about to say andrew campbell
but
it's andrew cameron cameron is [ __ ]
scottish
and he's irish german
next question
i think there's a nose smartphone
all right i'll take that out no that's
not like uh four heads i'll take that l
on that all right andrew uh you're not a
jew my bad if you're watching
so which one is it
i think you opened i'm gonna go with
opening
that is false
i creature once closed
yeah but it's really just not because i
was headlining or anything like that
what happened it's just because it was a
show uh that the health if he had for
just for last and it's not so much that
i yeah i closed the show but it put me
last
like after mike because he just asked me
like oh [ __ ] how are you doing right
after we you did our show oh so you
weren't an actual closer but you did
close close the show okay that's what i
said okay hey it's your question
yeah i'll give it to you okay yeah your
questions are trash though no no not
because
did i open did i close the door or did i
slide underneath it was like maybe it
was the same three things the three
times they're not the same thing did i
go 290 260 or 255 different things but
you don't drive you don't know dude did
i did i eat the the apple the orange or
the pear
sorry all right
i'll give it to him though
yeah preach wins today two three yeah
you just mad cause you lost i'm mad
because
your question is trash you're just mad
cause you like message quest you know
what which one that you had that was
good though
the first one all of them so the first
one was pretty good was the first one
and then i think the second one was the
one where you
um
the second one was the one where you
were talking about whether or not
you
s
see the one where you're running from a
car all that [ __ ] is like yeah you don't
ramble
in what country and in what state and
what i'm not saying none of that yeah
you were violating with those questions
that's like it was my dick seven inches
six inches or eight inches it's like
you couldn't move
you know for my deduction skills i've
seen the outline and the jogging pants
and seven inches
you don't even have to do that one you
don't have to try
you don't have to do that
what is wrong with you do you know
what's wrong
talk about my dick line but anyways let
us know
let us know what you guys think of the
comments below what you thought of his
questions but shout out to preach for
getting the first dub of the day oh one
thing uh one thing you see how this face
is empty uh and on the instagram we have
a p.o box send it and like if you want
to send us stuff and whatever your
beautiful artwork send it and we'll hang
it somewhere in the space yeah and if
it's trash it goes to the garbage
yeah that's him
choosing
what are you gonna do with the trash
stuff i'll put it
aside just kind of looking at me like
i'm crazy i know you're gonna put no
doodle up there yeah let me know yeah
yeah no you're not so you're not but
it's all good anyways hopefully you guys
enjoyed today's episode we'll be doing a
lot more of these so make sure you
subscribe to this channel it's gonna be
different content than what we do on the
main stuff not as controversial but
still sometimes that's enjoyable and
interesting it won't be fun
get us there